so Ed Davey very good morning to you as
we were just discussing their your party
the labor party the SNP all want a
general election but you're not going to
get one are you
well I agree with I love what Rob said
but also what a conservative MP
Christopher Choate said early on in your
broadcast this morning he said he wanted
a general election and I think you'll
find that there are a number of
concerted MPS who when they look
themselves in the mirror they'll realize
what a shambles the conservative party
is now how divided it is how incapable
it is of governing our country and I
think they'll also recognize that
they've got no mandate now so little
Democrats have been saying given Liz
trust trashed our economy with her
unfunded tax cuts Boris Johnson before
her failed our country with his lies and
his law breaking it really is time that
the conservatives were swept from power
and that requires a general election
but the truth is that Tory MPS will look
themselves in the mirror and think I
don't want to lose my seat
well you probably right I what I'm doing
is calling on them to put the national
interest first above their party
interest it's time they did their
patriotic Duty our country is in in
crisis you know we've got mortgage rates
going up energy bills food bills fuel
bills I talked to my constituents you
know they're they're really really
fearful of this winter there's going to
be people going cold and hungry there
are millions millions of families who
are struggling the moment pensioners
hundreds of thousands of businesses
and that's because of the conservatives
they have failed our country in the most
egregious Dreadful way they don't
deserve to lead our great country and
they should go and you know again as Rob
your correspondence just said they are
so divided they are incapable of
providing the strong political stability
which is an essential prerequisite of
getting the budget right the economics
right so we can really help people and
get our economy going
well you said that but there is a new
Chancellor that's been installed and
wouldn't you say that he's brought some
economic stability already and we'll get
a full outline of his fiscal statement
in just over a week's time
well only compared to what went before
um we're still seeing a weak pound we're
still seeing higher interest rates we're
still seeing inflation and to be honest
he's not doing the sorts of things that
liberal Democrats have argued for a long
time it's over a year ago now that
little Democrats and I put forward the
case for a windfall tax on the record
profits of all a gas companies made
because of President Putin killing
innocent ukrainians surely it's moral
and fair and right to tax those huge
profits so we can afford in responsible
way to help families and pensioners out
there and and business struggling with
energy costs that would be a fair
approach and we're not hearing that from
uh from the government
um I've just been shown a tweet by Jacob
rees-mogg he's just tweeted I'm backing
Boris what do you make of the
possibility of a return by Boris Johnson
well that would just be another terrible
scandal from the conservatives let's
remember Boris Johnson
lied on an industrial scale he broke the
law he failed to handle a sex abuse case
in his own ranks properly and it was
Tori MPS who didn't have confidence in
him who got rid of him are they all
suffering from memory loss can they not
remember what an absolute disaster Boris
Johnson was and I think it would be
a scandal if they allowed him to stand
let alone voted for him
he called for him
for him running
the next leader
well of course they can decide but they
should be judged by the British people
about the decisions they make let us
remember there is a privileges committee
inquiry into whether Boris Johnson
misled Parliament the British people at
the dispatch box when he was prime
minister
and many of us believe he did
and if he did that is a resignation
offense it's a very serious offense
so what the toys would be doing if they
allow him to stand
is creating yet more political
disability allowing someone with his
track record to stand who if he were to
be elected I just hope he can't be it
would be such a disaster but if he were
he could then face being thrown out by a
palm tree committee findings in two or
three months time does that make sense
our country is in Peril do these
conservatives not realize that
he of course maintains he did nothing
wrong and is confident that he'll be
he'll be cleared in that doesn't he I
mean some people might say liberal
Democrats did quite well when Boris
Johnson was prime minister you won a few
by-elections when he was the leader of
didn't he
well you're right we did win a lot of
ball actions in True Blue uh heartlands
in in buckinghamshire we beat the
tourists and North Shropshire see the
tourists half of 200 years and then
Tifton Honiton uh in East Devon where we
overturned a record majority so you were
right though that we prospered but you
know what we're doing is putting the
national interest above our own interest
we think it is right for
Boris Johnson never never to go back
into number 10 and I would just urge uh
tour MPS to do likewise do their
patriotic Duty for once for once put the
national interest first that means
certainly not backing Boris Johnson and
preferably having general election
well yes but any new leader that comes
in will be able to lay out their plans
Jeremy Hunt has set out already at some
of the direction of travel and don't
they have the right then they'll have a
majority in Parliament they have a right
to see out the last two years of this
term don't they
well they can fail to listen to British
people
they can fail to listen to their
constituents
you're right in constitutional Theory
they can go on to I think it's January
2025 they can go on to if they really
want to but think of what damage that
will do to our country
um I I I'm almost speechless that the
tourists could be so so outrageous when
people are suffering at a level I've
never seen before I was just a the food
bank in my constituency last week they
say the numbers going there are have
never been higher and I think it's going
to get worse for many people when they
look at their mortgage costs I was
talking to a guy who runs a cafe near
near these Studios early today he was
saying he couldn't get staff his costs
are going up he's really worried about
the future he doesn't know how he's
going to pay his mortgage that's the
reality I don't see it's always
apologizing I don't think they've got a
plan they are divided and shambolic I've
never known it so bad and so for the
interest of our country if the interest
of millions of people and hundreds of
thousands of businesses they have to go
and liberal Democrats will keep making
that case and what we'll do also is we
will afford an alternative plan
that is costed that is responsible and
that is fair
you know British people go out to work
every day they they try their best they
bring up their kids they look after and
care for their relatives they run their
businesses all they want is a fair deal
from government and they are not getting
that fair deal from the conservatives
okay so Davey we appreciate your time
this morning thanks very much indeed for
talking to us thank you